OLIVIER DE WECK: Teamwork is
an essential part of the class.
Because any great system
or product is really
the result of a
teamwork, where in a team
you have to balance
essentially your own ideas
and your own desires with
what your teammates think.
And the dynamics
of successful teams
show that diversity
is important,
being able to openly
share ideas, also
the ability to compromise and
not always getting one's way.
What we found over the years--
and I think this is also
supported by research and
scholarship in design--
is that the optimal
team size is about five.
Four to six, maybe
up to seven people
is the ideal size of teams
for this kind of project.
And why is that?
If you create a
smaller team, you
have less diversity of ideas.
And you also have less man
or brain power, of course,
to get work done.
Since once you decompose the
project into its elements,
each of these elements
needs to be done carefully.
So you want to
have a team that's
large enough to do the work
within the time constraints.
On the other hand, if
the team is too large,
then there's a lot
of coordination,
there's a lot of overhead.
Just being able to meet whether
it's physically or online
becomes harder.
And the efficiency of
the team goes down.
And so we found that a team
size of about five people
is ideal for this
kind of a project.